flirting whale so this it's gonna blow  your veil back calm down Jesus Ryan  something new and in time you will find  the source of your power and I have a  frog in my voice snap out of it so yeah  sorry I wasn't ready for it oh that went  right to the mouth off and boy what what  do I wanna shoot my balls down 70 free  up with like four on it oh I think Rob  Brydon set it too soon someone should  have a word with him it is take with  gold or without put it off my leg damn  that was the worst piece of acting ever  we have the most acclaimed actresses of  our generation it's unbelievable  followed you sorry when I lost my ring  foul ball Evangeline chose well I am  Evangelic whisperer Beavis oh thanks  I'll be doing ventriloquism for a long  time